ça fait des années qu'on sait pas tous
retrouvés
pour fêter noël vous êtes tout pour moi
je veux rattraper le temps perdu
[Musique]
les autorités se demandent si le
justicier masqué qui a terrorisé la
pègre ne serait pas de retour
ont passé refait surface
qui nous au moins six mois et du coup
ces trois fois rien je serais rentré
pour noël je te le promets
[Musique]
je me suis fait beaucoup d'ennemis avait
beaucoup je portais ce costume
vous êtes hockey y est t'es qui toi pour
certaines personnes
[Musique]
le meilleur archer du monde
aussi ce que tu penses
tu as lu chérie je devrais être de
retour d'ici un jour ou deux c'est pas
dieu
aubin
les choses se sont dit
légèrement compliqué ça
[Musique]
m
trop dangereux
sûrement pas celle là ne parlait pas
comme si j'avais 5 ans
vous savez encore plus balèze que ça
sérieux
tu parles d'un joyeux noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jeunesse
et
qui sait mais elle pousse mais
là c'est bon 16e blog vidéo j'en ai fait
un presque tous les jours depuis premier
commence à manquer d' un peu tous
complètement les pédales
a los
carayos je recherchais
avoir des personnes sous les ponts
si vous êtes attaqués nous devait
dépendre
de frigo et bien poussé contre la porte
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas l'air d'être toi non
plus mais l'état du champ là je vais me
couper sur quelque chose leur qui tu
parlais tout à l'heure moi je parle à
moi-même des fois maintenant
tu as déjà tué quelqu'un
si on tient bon aussi longtemps que
possible ils finiront tous par mourir de
faim
c'est pas si je suis d'accord avec toi
sur ce point
m
[Musique]
et
pourtant question va vers le chemin
sortir personne qui survivra ça
les vidéos captées pendant les braquages
et mise en ligne sur les réseaux sociaux
sont l'oeuvre des deux jeunes gens ariel
sommers et dean tyler
sa place
le couple est maintenant suivie par des
millions d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux est considéré par beaucoup à mes
questions
salut je m'appelle ariel
ou depuis aussi loin que je me souvienne
j'ai toujours su qu'un jour je
deviendrai célèbre et
[Musique]
l'aïe
je me disais que je n'avais encore
jamais vu par ici
wisco
tu sais
c'est une toute petite ville
que je me casse de floride
peut-être je trouve quelqu'un qui veut
venir avec moi
[Musique]
une famille
par contre vide du cachet à
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que tu aimes le vert tu as de
la chance
[Musique]
j'étais un compte hier soir on a trois
mille followers pourquoi t'as fait ça un
truc comme ça c'est pas courant nous
rendre super célèbre maintenant on va
s'amuser
pour vous ça bouge bien à ce que je vois
c'est tétouan arrêts
le couple est suivi par des millions
d'abonnés est considéré comme une
version moderne de bonnie and clyde
les gens s'intéressent à moi et ça mais
moi là dedans comment tu crois que ça va
finir tout ça je sais pas une fille
d'intérieur
salaire de 30 compte de ce que ça peut
faire pour nous qui comprend plus rien
du tout à des trucs de réseau
[Musique]
les bébés
comme classique un pas mieux qu'un bon
vieux braquages de banques
tu quittes la maison sans dire au revoir
d'enfants public a besoin de s'isoler de
réfléchir
et complètement désaccordé je peux en
coin et qu'est-ce qui a l'amour
pour pas manquer
bon tu peux me passer les enfants
stopper ils sont pas là
tu es avec keira
[Musique]
bon c'est juste une petite crise
d'angoissé
maintenant et on vous coucher pendant
deux trois jours mais pas plus et
surtout pas de mélange et ça
c'est super beau c'est très calme tu
peux m'expliquer porte constamment dû
passer des maîtresses il est bien ta
femme tu es vraiment un coup
qu'est ce que tu fais là toi t'as pas
encore couchés maintenant qu'une boigny
voilà maintenant il fait nuit
on va bien dit que le piano serait
accordé ce n'est pas le cas ah bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement qu'est ce qui te fait penser
que je couche avec ton pote on va tuer
ça parce que c'est concret tellement la
peine histoire je venu ici pour l'isoler
excuse moi mon amour mais l'artiste en
panne d'inspiration qui part s'isoler un
cliché
[Musique]
malgré de faire un enfant pour en
arriver là
[Musique]
pour t'apprennent accepter certaines
choses de tard
les victimes de toi même
tu veux quelque chose qui n'existe pas
adam
j'ai l'impression que ça me fait du bien
de rêver
[Musique]
bon sens mélodique à
noter que c'est le cas
mi temps ils n'ont pas les mains ça vous
quittez s'agace t
[Musique]
tanoh in
so
un arrêt
et
de
sept
[Musique]
oh
woods a
sévi
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
des fois tu feras fontaine
jean moi je parle
adore la buterne carmi loin
[Musique]
ap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouvert ce matin